is an opportunity as the nets go for the  win  that will forever continue to motivate  him and drive the player we know karis  levert to be  [Applause]  didn't want to extend the game  said he was going to win or go home  and levert  could not quite get it to go as damien  lillard looks around at the clock and  knows  we've done it down by one levert for the  lead  it's over and portland survives  the portland trail blazers survive  and they will play in the play-in game  with lillard putting in 42 and mccullum  putting in 25  and levert had a chance to give him a  lead in the win  finishing with 37 an  exhausting and emotional game with two  terrific opponents tonight